A two-year-old pet Samoyed living in Jiangsu province...
...has shown a remarkable talent for math.
Tudou, or Potato, can add, subtract, multiply, and divide with ease.
This is how Lu Zesheng tests Tudou on his math skills.
How many digits does ten million have?
How many zeros after one in ten million?
Oh, seven zeros.
How much is 3.44 plus 3.56?
Even the written word poses no problems for Potato,...
...who recognized the figures with ease.
When told the cameraman's cell phone number,...
...Potato apparently memorized it...
...and was able to recall a specific digit when asked to by Lu.
What's the third digit of the cameraman's mobile phone number?
So, what's next for Potato?
Well maybe university if they start accepting dogs.